well joining me now is the author and
playwright Bonnie Greer talk to the
contributor and lawyer for Ron Adrian
and the podcast hosted across the pond
Hotel Jesus well welcome to all of you
um all right Paula
let's start with you because I know what
you're about to say is going to make me
infuriated and it's going to be utterly
and sufferable excellent uh these are
two crests that carry images of
sailboats yes it's got nothing to do
with slavery or racism
if that's your opinion then you're
entitled to have it it's a fact well you
don't know that peers and the historians
are being asked to look into that and
that's what should properly happen
shouldn't it because when you tell us
about history and how important history
is what we want to do is to ensure that
we have got this right and we are going
to grow from this experience yeah I'm
not growing up I'm getting I'm going to
deny it I am growing for Mystic Spirits
I'm growing very annoyed and I'll tell
you why why are we annoyed let me tell
you why
like everybody I know I thought slavery
was disgusting and I'm very very glad
that everyone came around to their
senses it was disgusting and that
Britain actually led the way in ending
the damn thing of course I do slavery
was disgusting however
it turns out the historians say
Manchester didn't adopt ships as an
emblem until 1842. yes 35 years after
the abolition of slavery so they would
have had nothing to do with it and how
do we know that we don't know that so
what you are doing is you are taking one
understanding of a situation so you're
believing these dorians will suit your
narrative it's not what I believe peers
let's be clear about this we're having a
debate and that's what is important to
be able to have a debate about something
that happened in history we shouldn't be
looking at amen little pictures of of
ships on a footballer's Crest bad who
cares well got nothing to do with this
well clearly I'm sure the players at
Manchester City and Manchester United
those who Advocate uh you know show
racism the red card no it's not gonna
happen they will care about it the
guardian which has just been caught with
its racism trousers down right because
it turned out they were founded by a
bunch of slave owners right so they're
the last people on Earth to be
utterly ridiculous I'll tell you why
well they've apologized every single
family in Britain if you go back far
enough you'll have people in their past
hundreds of years ago who employed
slaves almost certainly and therefore
and therefore we know that was wrong
then why should everybody today had
nothing to do with it become terrible
I'm apologizing for it it's about
education yes first of all just
education and the second thing it's
about you know this we always rewrite
history we wrote We rewrote World War II
because we found out about Bletchley we
didn't a person who grew up in the 50s
would have a different World War II than
a kid now because we found out about
Bletchley so we are getting more
intelligent and that's one thing that's
happening and I mean you can't be sick
hang on and the other thing
the the United Kingdom was actually on
the side of the Confederacy during the
Civil War and in fact was going to send
the ship to the Confederacy to fight for
it when it was started
okay and paid an Indemnity who is going
to pay me yes and my family reparations
for what the Vikings did to us well I
think you should seek it out
what I'm saying is once you start this
woke Rampage there is no end a bit like
the statues of historical figures
they're all guess what hang on let me
finish ladies give me a moment all
historical figures are flawed you can
find flaws in Mandela in Gandhi and
Churchill that's why they had to be
boarded up their statues at Parliament
Square so the mob didn't attack them yes
but if we take this route everything all
the time we have to be apologizing
paying for it why why is that hoopa's
arm what's wrong with an apology nothing
is wrong with that if you I'm very sorry
the hundreds of years ago people Blaze
it's not anything to do with hundreds of
years we acknowledge it we always do
that that is what history why should
footballers have to remove crests it's
not they contain images of ships which
according to many historians were
adopted as an emblem 35 years after
slavery was abolished well it was
abolished but it wasn't over okay and
that's all well we don't know that
but we need them we need to investigate
it why not All Ships could be racists
all right
my general point is this I think slavery
was horrific I think if you basically
chart back from almost any family in
Britain and America you'll find some
evidence somewhere that someone in the
family probably was employed in in using
slave slavery when it was going on uh
but I just don't understand the point of
this constant series now of
recriminations reparations apologies
guilt trips and so on I don't know what
point it serves
I worked uh at a tech company once
and we know how Rife they are with
leftism and in casual conversation in
the office I said you know I want to be
a national master in chess one day
and this white girl said to me she said
don't you feel offended that they use
the term master
in the title and I just looked at it
like you know that thought never crossed
my mind the same thing if I were to go
to the harbor and I would see a ship I
would not think of slavery right there's
a huge fascination with slavery amongst
black people where our educational
system our upbringing has tied us to
this travesty in human history
and made us want to identify with it
instead of identifying with richer parts
of our history now here's the issue that
this comes down to
um women are going to see the world
frankly different from men women are
very emotional so of course they're
going to be worried about you know
what's on the badge and all this stuff
when we look at the UK right the UK has
about
4 million Starving Children
right now and that doubled since the
past two years do you think that
children that are hungry care about some
badges they can't eat football badges
you know what leftism does is they try
to sidestep the real dilemmas and worry
about all these Frills on the outside on
the exterior Hotel
apart from saying that you've made two
really good friends here with your women
get to emotional I'm from the south side
of Chicago
and I'll let you three deal with that
after the show but really impressed I've
got two things to say to what you just
said one is there was a genuine debate
in Australia several years ago because
an academic went on the Airways and
claimed that chess which you just talked
about was racist because the white
pieces went first right and I remember
thinking at the time the only time
anyone in the world would think that
that was the case was if some academic
decided to pop his head up and go it's
racist nobody actually believes chess is
racist for that reason and secondly on
your second point about current things I
read today that there are between seven
and eight million slaves in India alone
at the moment now correct now if the
Guardian newspaper wants to launch a
campaign against slavery in India I'm
all in I'm all in for any current
slavery going on anywhere in the world I
will join that campaign but going back
several hundred years to a spurious
argument which turns out may not even be
historically correct about badges on
football players where they show ships
therefore All Ships are racist and
therefore they must be removed to me is
preposterous well they do the same thing
here in America they wanted to remove
Aunt Jemima from product packaging then
one is tear down statues they're tearing
down
um Lee uh rabity lee I believe his name
was famous that to happen brother a
whole bunch of people are involved in
what uh Jay-Z as a quote it goes moral
victories are for minor league coaches
when you really want to get into the
nitty-gritty of things you look at more
important issues than just badges on the
football uniform I just don't get it do
you know something uh you just used the
phrase nitty-gritty that itself has been
banned now no yes
I have seen people say that is a racist
term yeah yeah and then and historians
so you accepted these historians who pop
their head up saying all the stuff can
be because it's completely wrong first
of all I want to get your Collective
reaction to the suggestion that this is
really a female thing you women are a
little over emotional about that I've
never heard a man say that for a long
time right so that I think that an hour
what is your what is your response I
would like to ask him what he thought
about the um American football uh clubs
who have changed their names because
they referenced various members of of
society who didn't think that it was
appropriate that they should be
um called those names we have uh rugby
clubs who have changed their names
because they didn't think that it was an
approach we're not talking about we're
not talking about potentially or
inflammatory names which have evolved
over the years we're talking about
images of boats I also went with their
boats
because she wanted to know my opinion on
I believe it's the Washington Community
no we have names brother
I'm sorry we have say that again brother
who's assisted that uh
that was sisters that's so nice thank
you Mr Parker
and I'm on your side but when I see a
football team changes names to
commanders you know I is I'm like you
know what is that are you insulted are
you feeling salted you feel insulted
well Commander
he feels shaken up surely no no is it
the word Commander itself it doesn't
that suggest you know white supremacy
because most commanders around that time
were white and your name change it to
something that also is racist there is
no word
Egyptian pharaoh so you know give us
give us are you uh offended by all of
this or what I'm not a fit why would
that's the whole thing people are
offended by the name of the team I'm not
offended
listen you're okay I'm not black people
who want to actually pursue an injustice
from the past it's not a strange thing
it's not unusual it is not no no no no
no no no no no you can't conflate those
two things oh I'm doing it I am I am for
that okay
yes sir no no what she said is just
inaccurate she tried to conflate two
things she tried to say I didn't care
about the travesties and conflate that
with something about the football team
is going to change that no I agree with
you there are real issues that need to
be dealt with changing the football team
is basically not tackling the problem
exactly right it's a way to waste time
it's a way to waste a budget if if we if
we admit to and this is in cycle
analysis that there is such a thing as
generational trauma okay it does exist
it does exist in families and it can
exist in a people now I'm not going to
go all the way and say do this tear
statues down because I don't think
statues taking statute down solvers
anything you're going to go off to the
badges
if that isn't a racist term I don't know
maybe horses get offended here's my
point Paula everybody is offended by
everything and so once you agree with
you once you assume that we have to
start feeling guilty for our past there
is no end to it
I think the Irish
emotional terms
what I would love to do is have a
campaign to close down the guardian I
think they'll be hugely popular I think
because of their outlandish links to the
slave trade the guardian should fall on
their own virtue signaling swords and
close themselves down as a matter if
they should cancel themselves so if
you're watching Guardian jealous I know
you probably are your guilty pleasure if
you're watching cancel yourselves
tonight and they'll do what you say it's
the right thing to do you are tarnished
by your slavery background and you must
end the Guardian newspaper as a matter
of urgency in the National interest and
then you can all run off and feel guilty
for the rest of your lives about the
shame do what you say on everybody and
when you're writing up your checkpies
you remind you how to spell my name I
know how to spell your name
first of all ready for my check from the
Romans and the Vikings
aggressively pursuing uh
spirited debate as always and thank you
very much indeed over to America thank
you probably quite a good thing for you
you are several thousand miles away
because you're good they're beginning to
see him over I think you've got them
with the emotion line uh thank you both
uh all three of you very much